so speaking of jj yeah he sent me
somebody new
addressadia addressed
address just is she gang stock jj is she
is she gank stocked
is is this pink haired weirdo gang
stocked or blue hair to what
color blind addressadia is she a gangsta
i need to know because i didn't know
what music i need to play is she a
gangstock victim
she is okay
i have it on my stream deck i have the
sound dropper i have the something on my
stream deck
one button away from it
hi jj all right i figured
now i'm calling to talk to you all right
hearing up truce hands up yeah hands up
hit them
all right uh so this particular one
right here
oh god everyone's strapping because
all right so her name is mary but
andreas
is her her pen name is the best way
she's a writer
if you didn't know is she all right do
you remember the bit back in the day
that uh marie did where she read a
certain person
from in their basement but a morgue oh
yes yes yes
all right so i have done that bit with
her book
and it took me a month to read it but
goddamn was it fantastic was it a good
book
it no no no it's not a i'll send it to
you
okay i'm happy to read but anyways uh
she
was a florida girl originally so there
you go ah
um she was
raised by me ma okay
and i'm trying to get all this straight
because there's a lot to go through
raised by
me ma raped by her dad
and some other guy that had hiv but she
didn't get aids
because she took the pill allegedly
um she left florida in a hurricane
to come to l.a which is where she's at i
know i'm doctoring her but she says at
15
uh where she was homeless and living in
a truck
uh for i think like six or seven months
and then now
she just got her section eight housing
and i'm telling you
the low milk flows all right from this
cow
all right so this one the for this video
is stands with uh sophia supporters need
to stop before they ruin her voice being
heard
any context on that or just play it uh
share your screen side
i know where we're at there buddy yes
sir give me a second here thank you
thank you
i'm producing on your own show thanks
there you go
you got it did it pop up yep okay good
all right let's see
uh i feel like whenever
something gets popular and a lot of
humans get together they just
ruin it that's okay it happened with
bruno
and now it's happening with sophie so
here's the thing
sorry um with jj at least she's
beautiful
oh yeah you didn't tell you didn't tell
me she was beautiful frozen
says she looks like nathan lane and i
kind of see that yeah
hey i don't have audio in your skype for
some reason just let me know
what you don't have audio from the video
yeah it's weird
that is weird what is that i'll tell you
that
what is that about i don't know wait let
me see something
this might it might be this tell me he's
here now
sophie needed to be hurt
what the [ __ ] i don't know don't worry
i'll just make up words that she said no
no no no no no no no audio and videos no
no this should work i don't like when
it's i don't like what my things don't
work hey royce
royce if we went to discord it would
work a whole lot easier
i am oh i see what the issue is
hold on see this is what i was talking
about the producing
that i do for this show you know i get
there we're peers and i have my own show
and whatnot but cocky
don't don't go i deserve to be whatever
what about this do you hear this
sophie needed the attention you're good
okay
continue okay she did i'm not denying
that
and we successfully got that attention
we got her voice heard who's we
uh all of the people in her head
oh okay okay so she's she believes she's
gank stock too right
yes okay cool well i don't know
she's she's stalked on the internet
because you you'll
she's gonna her takes are so hot fire
you're just gonna love it
so you'll see why she gets i'm excited
being
heard it's in the court system there is
a restraining order against the man
that's doing it the mother's boyfriend
well but she said she lives in her car
the restraining order says she has to be
10 car links away from somebody right
yes okay good sophie is being heard
now is a time that we
need to step back and let the court do
their work
but that's not happening because now
there's people setting up protests
at the police station where they're
going to be doing the change over
tonight
she's going to be going to be with the
father for the weekend
and people are like yeah let's let's
who's she i'm sorry who's she talking
about
uh sophie the stamina sophie thing
okay remember that okay show up with
signs
and support for the child well but
that's not that no
because this is a custody battle and
this
mother i like that she has one of those
crystals on her necklace
now pay attention to that crystal
because it never moves okay
all right and i mean it never moves
that's disgusting of a woman
oh my god you're right she is going to
use everything
she can to keep that child because she's
making money off of her
guaranteed she said that
she watched it happen which means that
she probably
films it and sells it i
i promise y'all this goes deeper
than than just one little girl being
touched by one man
but if y'all are showing up with signs
and screaming
in masses over this the judge is going
to feel like
sophie's not safe with either parent
and then dad's not okay
let's play another video from ours what
do you say yes
so uh basically i'm done
um this is gonna be my last trip to la
i have terminated services with my
doctor and
my therapist on the grounds that
i do not feel like i'm being treated
like a human being
i'm
it's been a full month
since i've had a shower what
yes sir this is an onion that as soon as
you start on peeling it it just gets
worse and worse and worse and worse
how was she not at a shower in a month
dude she's been in her section eight
housing and she still probably hasn't
showered in a month
and there there's a reason why i can
show you why
okay um in her videos uh her
her the person that lives above her has
has a leak uh so and this is now this
video is probably
i'm gonna guess seven months old okay
uh but the mo the more recent ones in
the uh section eight ones are fun
so this is this is the homeless days
okay
i was so excited
about getting a shower today
for the past couple of days
all i've been thinking about is that i'm
gonna get a shower
on tuesday
i got here and i went through all of
that
hell with the police trying just to get
here
just to find out that i still can't get
a shower
they don't care
that it's been a month they don't
care that it'll be another month
they don't care that this might not be
over then
that's three months without a shower
they don't care they don't dream on
me as a person
so i've terminated my services with them
i will no longer be taking medication
or okay all right
let's see here good god
how many tabs you know 87 tabs there's
more than the 64 you had last time
so she finally got a shower yes she got
a shower oh this is a good one
she got a shower she got a shower okay
let's see
well all right hold on hold on hold on
hold on what happened here is she got
into uh one of the uh
la like homeless bravo hostile things
that you can't stay in
okay so she got placed in there for a
while while she was waiting for section
8 housing
so she's living with a bunch of other
homeless crazy ass
right so i don't know what the hell
happening but i'm uncomfortable
is that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] somebody [ __ ] in the shower
someone [ __ ]
in the shower homie oh no
no no no no
i told you this was a cherry i've been
holding on to this one for a while and
i'm like man
whoever gets this is gonna be a [ __ ]
a goddamn camaro of a [ __ ] train
wreck here
oh no
[Music]
yep that's poopy
yeah something tells me i shouldn't go
and take a shower
for a while nope gonna be another month
and what is oh god oh did she get mad at
kitty
oh she gets mad at a lot of people okay
so kitty of course we know kitty helps
kitty kitty's probably one of the the
premier miners for this
she's just [ __ ] she mines for this
gold all the time
um she got mad at kitty because i guess
kitty posted something
uh well what happened was she made a
video about
her yelling at somebody she had just
moved into the apartment
and like it was literally the first day
she was in the section eight apartment
okay
and someone that was living there stuck
their head in the [ __ ] door to be
like oh someone's living here and she
[ __ ] lit
into them and kitty reminded her that it
could be just a neighbor or maintenance
man or whatever so
you'll see okay
last video i made about the leak
kitty b replied just remember
you went full caring on a concerned
neighbor
just looking out for your property you
could have thanked him for his concern
and introduced yourself instead of
ripping his head off
i'm sure he hopes you go back to the
shelter too
never forget this is all your
fault he's an instigating [ __ ] and i
love it
the uh the in her bathroom
uh above her tub there was this leak
every time that the neighbor the
neighbor upstairs would take a shower
it would leak into her [ __ ] bathroom
so and by the way that's happened uh
spoiler alert two times
since this incident okay like she
literally every other day there is
something wrong
i am a human being
are you though because so far from what
i've seen i'm gonna
a hard maybe on that one real hard
i'm a single woman i wonder why you have
such a lovely personality
with multiple mental disorders honey i
think you just answered your own
question
she does that a lot cptsd
bipolar uh-huh completely anti-social
wait one more she has a job
that's a jackpot yeah she hit the jack
but she has all the diseases
i told you this was a cherry she makes
[ __ ] cash look like a rocket
scientist
yes
[Music]
a concerned neighbor
walked into my apartment without
knocking
or asking or introducing himself
he just pushed the door open and walked
right
in okay
and what i'm supposed to suck his dick
well hold on a second i don't know i
just went to a hunter real quick
yeah i don't whoa you just told me i got
whiplash
with that one wait a second i don't
think anybody was implying you had to
suck this man's penis
he was a maintenance guy he was a
maintenance guy right
uh i honestly we don't know i think it
was
just someone that lived there and was
like oh [ __ ] there's someone that moved
in here
got it hi
welcome to the neighborhood i'm a good
girl i get down on my knees just like
i'm supposed
i know she's being sarcastic but i feel
like she would
uh and her there's been past times in
her life where i believe she would too
it's not gonna be good no of course not
it's gonna be terrible
if a man i don't know comes into my home
i fight so
[ __ ] you for thinking that my roof leak
is my own fault because i stood
up for myself against a man
who decided it was his right to
walk into my apartment yeah kitty [ __ ]
you who do you think you are
she's a hero when he did not
know me he did not ask
me nobody asked me if some
random man could just walk into my
apartment
he wasn't working for the landlord he
wasn't just checking on a concern
he wasn't just concerned
for all i know he could have been coming
in to steal from me himself deal what
your
cans i have a feeling you don't have
anything to steal here lady
because every time somebody has come
into my home
and stolen from me they have always said
well i thought it was mine
i lived in a tent for multiple years and
every couple of nights a man would kind
of come into my tent he would unzip the
tent
and i would scream and kick his face and
he would always say oh i thought it was
my tent
people would walk off which is a common
problem tents look a lot
yeah no they do that's a good point left
outside
strollers and stuff that was too big to
stay in the tent and they would say no
it's mine
it's mine it's definitely mine
definitely [ __ ] mine
so no i do not deserve this god that's a
really good point
somebody post kitty posted this 11th
when she made this video 11 seconds ago
somebody says wow she really thinks
things through she doesn't just jump in
to make videos
no 11 seconds ago and she's
already and another thing
dude you should have seen all right so
there's a duck video that you need to
get there's
a lot to go through no of course so when
you get to the ducks
uh what do you not feed ducks royce
what do you not feed ducks i don't know
hang grenades
well uh you don't throw rice at them oh
no of course not any birds because it
expands in their stomach
okay yeah that's what everyone knows did
she kill ducks
[Laughter]
did she kill ducks i told you i told you
this is
a [ __ ] onion that the more that you
unfucking furl from it the better it
gets
so is the video that she made just
titled ducks
uh it's bird feeding time
okay or actually all right so there's a
set of videos where she
meets the ducks okay right and then she
goes home
and gets the rice and comes back and
feeds
the ducks okay so this this is okay so
it's
food today i got my
number early this morning
oh wow she's
it's pretty [ __ ] crazy she's [ __ ]
yeah so
we have soup first and then they're
gonna bring food out in about an hour
but i wanted to i saw these ducks
homeless eat up i think these are the
same little baby ducks
that i saw last year when they were
first born
when i was sleeping this park
are they pretty they got big
so fast like literally
six seven months ago they were just
these little walking balls of fluff
and now they're actual ducks
i don't know where the others are there
were eight the others must have
separated a little bit
always so there's a line i gotta get in
for food but
what city she in l.a
l.a looks like [ __ ] hell uh there's
the actual duck feeding murder
uh kill squad that she got she got gotta
kill tacular with this
all right all right anyways i came this
morning i got my number i'm number 82.
i don't know how many people there are
going to be here but the last time i did
this i was
number 168 so
at least i'm higher up in line this time
but i've still got an hour to wait
before they start passing it out
moving on up in the hobo line
man maybe we should hook up with nomad
sam right dude
at least they'd [ __ ] get along like
they both hate everyone all right bird
feeding time
bird feeding time way back with the
birdies and the rice i don't know how
i'm gonna do this with one hand but
i'll figure it out won't i hey guys i
came back
okay some ducks she also said that she
needs to
uh hold on to everybody she's gonna say
it i don't want to spoil it
there you go don't give up don't give
the birds rice
hey peta this isn't us okay we're just
covering it
like a news story this is a duck murder
okay accomplish two murders what they
are
also if you're homeless why would you
give away your rice
all right so royce she get she got how
much from the uh
trump bucks the second time uh wasn't it
1200 bucks right
uh no the second time it was 600 600
yeah yeah
all right so her rate is 38
a month um just so you know don't ask
your mom i know that but
oh yeah cause she's told us 52 [ __ ]
times but anyways
she got 600 all right she got the 600
on a monday uh-huh all right by friday
how much money did she have
oh i hate math problems um
she had negative money she had negative
money oh no
now where did a hundred dollars go
i mean okay i'm gonna assume it won for
rice
she literally gave away a hundred
dollars to someone on the
internet what that was having
kid problems and they had their problems
you're homeless
yeah so she sent a hundred dollars to
her with the implication that she was
gonna get it back when that
uh undocumented immigrant brought their
six hundred dollars
as soon as the hundred dollars cleared
the
scam was unveiled and she found out she
lost
uh all of her money and she couldn't pay
her uh
her rent you can't you can't be a
generous homeless person
yeah see like all right so we do this
and we take
tips right because it's like why the
[ __ ] not man i'm putting on content if
you feel like giving me money cool
if not enjoy the content right all right
she literally will be like i lost a
hundred dollars i need
this or hey i need curtains can someone
get on my amazon wishlist and get
curtains
hello birdie they're sleepy
because it's early in the morning but i
wanted to make a video
no she needed to make a video because we
spent like three days telling her that
rice kills ducks they're not dead
see it wiggling his tail it's live
and somebody else came and cleaned up
the habitat
now all right i was gonna mention that
but you didn't play it in the last video
she bitched
the the the leaves and everything was
inside of that
i don't even know what that is i guess
that's an la river
um and [ __ ] that there was leaves and
[ __ ] in there and someone needed to come
and clean it up
let me ask you a question why does this
video say mayonnaise hair mask
uh because she's about to put mayonnaise
in her hair
so we're set up to do this in the
bathroom because
i don't like icky things don't look at
her teeth or her nails
so i want to be near a sink
i went and i bought me some mayonnaise
because i didn't have any
she didn't even get dukes that's what
pisses me off about it
she got the shitty mayor yeah dukes are
superior mayonnaise i will agree with
you
if you're gonna do something do it right
and i also
got this which is apple cider vinegar
for what is she making a salad in her
hair
yes yes that's exactly what she's doing
she's salad
rinsing it out which
that's something that my grandmother
used to do
me mom now watch this all right so
anyways what they tell you to do
not about to do this dollop on your hand
and you run it through there
there this is a thing believe it or not
um
you're supposed to put it in your hand
and whatever and it's supposed to make
it softer
um and let's see what she does which is
yeah not how you do it but it's supposed
to start at the roots
and work down spill
me move my hair around a little bit
there she is miss hobo america
actually you know what i do i do have
something for this uh
specifically for this situation
um here it is
yeah right she's the perfect triple ass
face
look i never thought i never thought i
would have ever say this on my show and
i've said a lot of weird [ __ ] on my show
but let's get to the part where this
crazy homeless person put mayonnaise in
her hair
there you go never thought that was
going to happen nope
here it goes why is it doing the party
thing it literally has just been opened
not the first time that's too much
mayonnaise
oh my god that's already too much
mayonnaise
right it's supposed to be a dollop
what are you making potato salad in your
head
oh no oh god no oh no oh no
now believe it or not this is not the
worst white thing she's ever put in her
hair
[ __ ] christ
that looks almighty yes because
it's [ __ ] mayonnaise in your hair
just look how happy she is to do this
though
okay the calm i think is gonna be cool
boy says not only is she beautiful but
she also has a great personality
mitch is in the chat who is this
well-adjusted human
uh mitch of this is somebody that jj
brought over what's your real name
uh mary barone mary barone and
mitch mitch knows this because he lives
out in the sticks have you ever heard
putting
putting a gallon of mayonnaise in your
hair makes it better
it makes it soft soft
oh god yeah mitch you're gonna love this
one [ __ ] she knows
it's not annoying in any way no
and and hey mitch she likes lakes you
like lakes
huh
problematic i'm probably gonna have to
use my hands yeah
royce this is a long video i i know it's
long jj
there's a lot to get a lot to unpack no
she's putting more mayonnaise
you already have too much mayonnaise
there's already too much mayonnaise
mitch says we don't have your fancy
orlando shampoo stores
that's a very funny mention
i might gag oh [ __ ]
oh god does she have lice
is it for lice maybe uh well again i
don't want to spoil anything but she
does have a way to get rid of lice
um okay you would be shocked at
that knowing that but it's it's jj
gg it's a cartoonish amount of
mayonnaise right here
yes why is she putting so much
mayonnaise in her hair i don't this is
why
i follow these people oh no
what the [ __ ] man
instead of the noise it sounds like
shaney's sex tape
hey if we were in discord i can hit it
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah ball powder makes a good point
hey jj she will be making a new video
about this place today do not go there
and comment on her [ __ ] she will [ __ ]
about it i'm telling y'all don't tell
her
day way over jj safety please don't do
that
are you being sarcastic don't [ __ ] do
it no i'm not i'm [ __ ] serious
i don't want this [ __ ] knowing i exist
fair enough
you're supposed to work it in real good
and then let it sit for 20 years
you sit in the sun until it rots so the
mayo rots in your hair
now all right so royce if you had to
make a choice would you put gorilla glue
or mayo in your head
i would put it out of those two choices
i would pick option three a bullet
so i'm going to let it sit for the 20
minutes 20 minutes she's gonna sit with
mayonnaise in her hair for 20 minutes
yes and i'm gonna
wash it out and then i'm gonna rinse my
hair after i wash it with the
apple cider vinegar this reminds me of
when michael scott got gum in his hair
and he just started taking it out that's
part of the reason why you uh
you you do the mayo treatment as if you
got that's what my old lady taught me
she was like well does she have gum in
her hair i'm like no she's she's a hobo
she just has hobo head
and we will see if there's any
change to my hair aside from it being
greasy now which is gross as [ __ ] oh my
god she's putting more
yeah next next video she's going to be
putting
things on her teeth to fix that too but
i don't think it's possible oh my god
by the way happy birthday to the dustin
tv show happy birthday dustin
and you're right the sound is legendary
it's everything about this
done anything like this with your hair
no because i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
well first i have good hair and royce is
bald i'm bald yeah so but would i i mean
i guess you know what jj you didn't
think about this we could get our beards
nice and soft though
oh see now we got to do the mayo beard
challenge
beard challenge baby ever like
tried a home mask or
anything crazy my grandmother
used to like i said put apple cider
apple cider vinegar online
apple skargers i had lice a lot as a kid
talking's hard when your hands full of
mate would put kerosene in my hair
there you go yeah
me mom put kerosene in her head she
would put [ __ ] kerosene in her hair
to kill the lice yes that's what
meanwhile did for her
and then she would smoke a cigarette
while she was doing it right behind
yep this is why she has short hair
listen so she would have to then all do
all kinds of crazy stuff
to like
repair the damage that the kerosene had
done
it's an all or the gran it's it's just
it's one of those old
old remedies that they don't tell you
about you know they don't do it anymore
this is something that dr park
frankenstein would use
okay so i'm gonna try to comb it through
but i don't know
i don't think it's gonna work i doubt
that this is gonna work
it's not oh look she's the fawns now
hey
that's a good screenshot right there it
really helps that's the thumbnail for
the day
it is it is here let me let me actually
i'm i'm going to full screen it so
people could grab it if they need it
there it is
click it's just it's too good
it's it's too good okay
i've been sitting on this little while
just trying to figure out who i want to
dump her on
because like i'm not done [ __ ] with
her
because just she's so she's a constant
constantly dude constant and now that
we've
see when i pass them on it usually gets
affected in some way
right of course um and and you know the
dustin effect that actually went well
usually it doesn't go well
you know ditch uh dashton disappeared
yeah he's [ __ ] he did that that one
really bums me out
like he took that entire channel down
where he was fighting with his meth
boyfriend
well he's still got the other one up he
put one up the other day where he's
playing with
kid toys that's normal normal normal
this is probably her best video ladies
and gentlemen attacked by a dog and it's
shitty owner
all right let's uh let's see
the dog bit me and you don't care but
you're taking care of this animal
are you okay whoa okay i'm backing up
there's a lot
this actually may be the first one to
make it up to the main show out of all
mine
well the second one okay let's see
name the dog bit me and you don't care
but that little dog yeah that one
you're taking care of this animal
are you okay now you're attacking me
your dog bit me
and now you're attacking me am i done to
you
no [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here dude
don't [ __ ] with these [ __ ] la women
man they'll [ __ ] you up they're in the
ms 13 and [ __ ]
i wouldn't [ __ ] with these people
your dog attacked me now you're
attacking me i feel bad for the dog
actually
doesn't those streets look so clean look
who wouldn't want to live in l.a
so dog attacked me and then she attacked
me
her [ __ ] dog attacked me this woman
has a dog off the leash
that is biting people my ankle is
bleeding
i don't think that dog did a lot of
damage because i was walking by
collecting recycling
and that little dog bit me
and i said is that your dog she said no
right
and then she starts calling the dog by
its name
so i said if it's not your dog how do
you know its name
who are you talking to us
oh the viewer yeah i see her we're part
of the story so this is
this is p this is one of those pov
things where you get to feel what it's
like being a crazy homeless person
yes zack morris but this time she just
smells like a hobo
got it she's constantly denying
she smells like dust and diamond now
then it's her dog but she's taking care
of it
and she knows its name and she picked it
up and she attacked me
i want somebody to come and get that
[ __ ] dog
and put it with some people that can
take care of it because that [ __ ] was
letting me run around biting people
i'm [ __ ] i'm out here collecting
recycling
you're you're collecting garbage so you
could get coins for it so you could
buy more mayonnaise for your hair um no
actually here's where i have to admit
something
she she is a weed head so that's for
weed she uses all her money for the
weeds
there you go you guys are two peas in a
pod yeah
unfortunately there's good in the bed
you know yeah
mike tessa says i'll get you your pretty
little dog too
then the door indoors for a month and
[ __ ] dogs are biting me
they bite me in the street
because i smell like a salad yeah
the dog is a boxer don't give a [ __ ]
you know it was her dog she just didn't
want to take responsibility
for her goddamn animal [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow that's [ __ ] cool going hard with
the c-bomb huh
yeah she likes colorful words and
using them this is in california by the
way
anybody out near mott oh no a bum made
fun of me what am i going to do with my
life
yeah so if you had a.g here and he
wasn't sitting around [ __ ] jerking
his dead leg off
uh he'd be able to tell us where the
hell that's at yeah he's sleeping
apparently he's like oh
sooner than lorem and i'll be up for the
show and what are your favorite a fart
in his face
what a [ __ ] terrible [ __ ] intern
he is
you know i'm i'm telling you he is damn
lucky i'm not there because i would be
the i'm hell on interns i'll get jerry
to set him on fire
desoto first that's where that [ __ ] and
her three
on desoto and first well we know exactly
where it is now like a dog that bites
people stays
so she also uh she likes riding the bus
now i don't i don't recommend doing one
of those now because those are kind of
long okay
okay oh this is a good one so this is a
short
that all right so she moved in first
there's a video
i honestly kind of think you might want
to save this for a little bit later
this is like a tease thing because
there's a video of what her bed was and
i'll have to go and find it
and then her solution to the bed
right is that video and then there's
more videos off of that so that's a
whole another
like 20 30 minute arc [ __ ]
okay that is i need playlists i need
playlists
i i will get you me and kitty will hook
you up with the uh
i i i need those okay so i think
so yeah i think we're good for today i
don't i don't want to i don't want to
get into
something and not be able to finish it
yeah there's a lot to that one
yeah i think we're done with with her
for today because if i were to i feel i
really don't want to get into something
and not be able to finish it
have you given the people the link so
they can go and not tell them that they
waving jj
all right guys i'm gonna give you the
link
i want to make sure that the one thing
you don't do is
don't let them know that jj stoner and
day wave radio sent you over there
okay don't do it don't okay there's the
damn shirt damn sure don't mention that
kitty was right
okay don't say the kitty was right and
don't don't say r.i.p
ducks because we don't want any of those
things okay mayo head for life yes tell
her that you love mayo too
okay all right i'm gonna pop off here
all right uh number
12. i'll see you all bye later buddy see
you
it's good my boy jj